should nato impose a no-fly zone over
ukraine as russia intensified air
attacks president vladimir zielinski
repeated his call but the western
military alliance says blocking airspace
would escalate the war
so who's right this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad zhum russia's invasion of
ukraine is intensifying with air attacks
on civilian areas artillery shells
destroyed several buildings around the
capital kiev
at least two bodies were pulled from the
rubble of this apartment flock russian
air raids on sunday killed at least 35
people at a military facility near the
border with poland that was the largest
attack on western ukraine since the
invasion began
homes and hospitals in harkev and
mariopol have also been hit
russia denies targeting civilian areas
ukraine's president says the attacks
show why nato needs to impose a no-fly
zone to protect civilians
and now i repeat again
if you do not close our skies it is only
a matter of time before russian missiles
fall on your territory on the territory
of nato and on the homes of citizens of
nato countries
members of parliament of nato member
estonia are the first to demand a no-fly
zone some or all aircraft would be
banned from flying over certain regions
any pilots violating the order risk
being shot down
no-fly zones have to be enforced by
military means nato could end up
engaging directly with russian warplanes
making the alliance direct participants
in the ukraine war
nato and the u.s previously imposed
no-fly zones when only one side had a
powerful air force such as in iraq and
bosnia in the 1990s as well as during
libya's civil war in 2011.
all right let's go ahead and bring in
our guests from kiev helena yanchenko a
member of the ukrainian parliament and
deputy head of ukraine's parliamentary
majority
from brussels robert pistel a senior
fellow at the kasimir pulaski foundation
in poland he's also a former nato
official
and from perth in australia alexi
moravioff associate professor of
national security and strategic studies
at curtin university a warm welcome to
you all and thanks so much for joining
us today on inside story helena let me
start with you today you and i spoke a
little over two weeks ago on this
program
at that time you were calling for a
no-fly zone what does it mean to you
today that despite repeated calls from
president zielinski
and so many others in ukraine
officials in nato have continued to
refuse to impose a no-fly zone
listen i will tell you what no-fly zone
means for ukrainian innocent citizens
and it means thousands of thousands of
innocent ukrainians woman children elder
people will be safe
you know that the crimes that russian
occupation troops are now committing in
marijuana and many other cities but
mariupol
the situation in mariupol is the worst
today deputy head of me deputy mayor of
mariupol reported that 20 000
civilians were killed in mariupol only
20 000 people do you imagine that do you
imagine the scale of these crimes of
russian troops in ukraine
and they hit marupa heavily from air
they hit it from aviation they hit it
with its grass tornadoes and stuff like
that they send muslims to the peaceful
cities of ukraine
20 000 innocent ukrainians killed in
only one city
and this is all happened
because
west and nato countries are not ready
because they fear i don't know what they
fear i don't know what they fear don't
they fear
thousands of people being killed
but because they still
fear to implement no-fly zone in ukraine
the crimes against humanities the
murders of thousands civilians are going
on on a daily basis i now i'm in ukraine
in kiev and
i should tell you that it is horrible we
are going through a nightmare
many cities many cities of ukraine are
going through a nightmare of it on a
daily basis we hear muzzles from our
windows on a daily basis it's it this is
the thing that you can't get used to
this is the nightmare that we live in
and no fly zone will definitely help to
stop these crimes of russian troops that
they commit and keep committing in
ukraine this is what no-fly zone means
and we believe
we
say we believe that no-fly zone should
be implemented otherwise the world will
not be a safe place to live anymore if
one country if one crazy
dictator called putin can send his
troops
to another country a sovereign peaceful
democratic country to start kill
civilians then world is not a safe place
anymore and that is why citizens all
over the world and politicians should
actually start acting
well more actively
robert you heard what helena had to say
there about all that's going on
throughout ukraine
we know nato's position which is that if
they were to try to implement a no-fly
zone they believe that could spark a
wider conflict let me ask you how much
risk is there from your perspective that
attempting to implement a no-fly zone
over ukraine would spark this far more
dangerous conflict
yes i mean my first of all my heart goes
out to arena and all the ukrainians it's
it's a tragic it's a it's a barbaric
attack that they are experiencing and
it's just you know
russia has put itself beyond the pale
let's just stress this
i'm a former nato official so i can
speak my
you know i'm speaking in a private
capacity i mean if it was up to me
first of all i would not put
the no-fly zone concept you know off the
table right
i would consider it more carefully
perhaps you know in terms of maybe a
partial
um no-fly zone concerning certain areas
mario ball is an absolutely uh you know
the most urgent example i mean
in tonight i mean first of all there is
nothing in international law which which
would kind of make this such a move
illegal ukraine has the right to sell
defense it has the right to ask other
countries
you know uh to to help uh and and and
and also
you know even
russian hypocrisy of the regime uh you
know kremlin as they're not even calling
it a war
uh the the the there is also you know
the right to protect
and shrine the new end documents
the problem is however that right now
you know there is no consensus in nature
and it's you know you you have to ask
these questions frankly in the capitals
particularly in washington
but also in major european capitals you
know when for instance my country poland
has offered quite a generous offer you
know for free
over 25 tech lanes there was a number of
countries in
again western european countries who who
said no no that's a bad idea even though
nobody was asking them to actually write
anything this is the reality that having
said all this you know it is true one
has to be
you know uh quite sort of
direct about this you know no-fly zone
would mean war with russia it's as
simple as that would bring it's not just
about sending a few planes here and
there it's about neutralizing
the actual potential which russia is
using i mean for example the attack on
average which is very close to the
polish border um you know uh took place
uh was uh from the russian territory
approaching right
so it would mean actually neutralizing
you know a lot of infrastructure
and perhaps even attacking russian um
you know uh russian planes and ukrainian
maybe russia so you know this is very
very serious stuff because you know
we're talking about the potential world
war three and i can understand
um you know the the reasoning provided
by a lot of leaders in nato countries
and you need as i said consensus you
cannot have notify zone you know done by
a few countries but at the same time the
moral case for doing more that it's
being done today is growing stronger
every hour not even every day every hour
alexi um you must have heard robert
there talk about the fact that if this
escalates you could have world war iii
on your hands from your perspective
is there a chance that nato could
reverse its decision
that they could establish a no-fly zone
what would need to happen in order for
that to occur
look i mean one of the ways how it can
be done first of all we need to talk
about practicalities even if nato would
hypothetically decide to introduce the
no-fly zone now it will be
it will face certain operational
limitations it will be limited by the
operational range of its aircraft which
will have to operate from nato airfields
because if they will try to deploy their
assets inside ukraine they will be uh
they will be designated as as targets by
the russian military
so
in order to
not not to create more escalation and
suddenly uh create this threshold beyond
which the conventional phase of the war
can become an unconventional phase of
the war i think
one way or another it has to engage in
some sort of a consultation and dialogue
is as absurd maybe as hypocritical as
may sound with moscow about introducing
as as the previous speaker just
mentioned perhaps a partial no-fly zone
for example in the first instance or
western parts of ukraine whether it's
manageable from from the logistical
perspective and where there is still
limited use of russia's offensive air
power and and that may create a degree
of sort of division of of
responsibilities over ukraine again as
horrible as it may sound because we're
in the middle of a human catastrophe
there and a disaster can a sovereign
country be not being attacked by a much
a much larger country and and a more
formidable military uh military power
but if if we're not talking about really
escalating the the confrontation and not
spilling the conflict beyond ukrainian
territory it can be done uh but it it it
has to it has to be done in some sort of
through some sort of a consultation
communication and that may not be
possible right this moment because i as
far as i understand often formal
communications between russia and nato
has been suspended if not terminated for
good helena i i saw you shaking your
head i know you want to jump in i'm
going to let you i also want to ask you
about a point that both robert and alexi
raised and there have been growing calls
for perhaps the establishment of this
idea of a limited no-fly zone perhaps in
the west of the country is that
something that would be acceptable to
ukrainians
well first i i would like uh to ask
alexey to stop putin's narrative this is
not confrontation this is not crisis
this is worth with thousands of
civilians killed you should realize that
and you should not
you you should not use putin's narrative
because putin's narrative kills it kills
real people in ukraine and you have no
obligation on
you should not like commit the crimes in
the media
second thing
no
partial no no fly zone is not working
like what are you talking about this is
this is like what let us save people in
one region
and putin and russian occupation army
can kill people in all other regions
is that what you suggest
can you imagine like
do you even imagine what you are talking
about
again let me remind you that 20
000
civilians meaning women children
older people other civilians were killed
only in one city in marijuana people are
stuck there with no food no water no
medication people are
dying because they can't get a treatment
people with diseases with with i don't
know with cancers with diabetes they
can't get treatment and they are dying
children imagine that children on
european continents are dying because of
dehydration
they don't have water to drink and they
die
do you imagine that
do you imagine going through such things
and then we see experts and you know
like politicians talking that no-fly
zone is not like
something that we should discuss now let
let's think about it later on
when another dozen ukrainians will be
killed when enough the million of
ukrainians will become refugees
is that what you're talking
about really helena can i what we should
helena may i ask you if nato continues
to refuse to establish a no-fly zone
what else would ukraine like to see in
the form of assistance if if they
continue to refuse that
natto is the biggest disappointment
of this year
natto is a total disappointment it's an
organization which cannot protect anyone
which cannot protect even its own
uh countries and we should realize that
we should not look
at nato we should actually communicate
and request for help for certain
countries which realize that putin and
russia is a threat
putin and russia is a threat for the
whole world for global security in the
majority of european countries in their
you know
strategic documents it's already said it
is already said for years that russia is
a threat
for global security it is a threat for
european security and nowadays we see it
all
we see that they kill people in ukraine
we see that russians like
we have thousands of witnesses like that
that russian soldiers are going into
residential buildings dragging people
from their apartments and so and shut
them dead on their yard this is what we
are going through can you imagine that
can you imagine this experience can you
imagine how many more years after we
finish this war after we win this war
for how many more years we will
we should like
treat our people so they can recover
from distress do you imagine that and we
still discuss when and who should like
impose no fly zone i think it's time
for
selenium countries
it's a shame i'm sorry to interrupt you
helena we are starting to run out of
time um i need to ask alexia question
here alexa you talked about
the feasibility perhaps of a of a
limited fly zone i want to ask you about
how difficult it would be to
achieve an expansive no-fly zone or
throughout the whole of ukraine
well as i coming back to the point that
i raised earlier first of all it would
be difficult logistically
just the sheer operational range of nato
aircraft would require
a different a different sort of
proposition
deploying for example seaborne assets in
the in the black sea would be impossible
given the operations and operational
activity of the russian black sea fleet
and the fact that the russians
effectively control the entire black sea
maritime theater
trying to neutralize russian defensive
posture in russia will automatically be
treated by moscow as the declaration of
war on russia and and
in the in the current circumstances
given the fact that nato three has three
nuclear-armed states that may
premeditate the escalation of the
conventional conflict
uh to to a nuclear phase again no one
knows whether pudding will
press the button or not press the button
but
certainly the decision makers in
brussels the decision making in pentagon
would not be at risk of entertaining the
option what if he will not press the
button because everyone who is serious
and who knows the business of strategic
and defense planning tends to operate
from what works case scenario upwards
rather than from optimistic scenario
downwards so given given the current
state of complete mistrust given the
current state of
countries not listening to one another
and certainly russia and the west being
on worse terms i mean the current
situation is much worse than the
the the the darkest years of the cold
war confrontation uh i think nato is
simply uh risk avoiding and and by doing
that i certainly completely agree with
helena it's is is doing industrial
damage to its reputation it's it's it's
actually undermine its credibility as
the world believes to be the most
powerful defensive alliance when it when
it doesn't
have the political will to challenge
russia over ukraine after years of
sidelining with ukraine after years of
providing military assistance to ukraine
after years of giving promises to kiev
about
eventual membership in the in its
defensive structure and with eu
providing similar sort of promises with
the eventual membership in the eu and
now it seems to be falling apart simply
because the russians decided to
undertake connection kinetic action
which is obviously unwarranted uh
aggression against the sovereign uh
sovereign nation it it really i mean it
really first of all undermines uh
european confidence in their own
strategic affairs it undermines i think
european confidence in the united states
as the private security guarantor on one
hand on the other hand it certainly
provides generals in moscow with
additional
confidence in exercising more legal
force because they can see that nate is
like simply too scared i'm challenged
i'm sorry to interrupt you alexi again
we are starting to run out of time i
need to ask robert a question robert i
saw you reacting it looked like you
wanted to jump in so i'm going to let
you do that but i also want to ask you
about the fact that the parliament of
estonia has become the first to demand a
no-fly zone of a nato member state do
you think there's going to be more
pressure from nato member states to try
to impose a no-fly zone
yes i mean you know uh this is by the
way i was shaking my hand because i i
now part company with alexa because he
was actually his last remarks he was
basically repeating you know uh
repeating scrambling narrative in more
such a way sorry uh you know we we are
much more united than you know
the important thing is this first of all
i
again i try to explain what the problem
is what you know but my you know
my sympathy is with elena because i
believe uh that you know we cannot just
watch this like you know
you know 20 000 people being killed in
maribor is is enough just you know to to
to
uh to demands to do more and i think the
public opinion in our countries will
grow much harder with every hour the
second point i would make uh and this is
where like say you are totally wrong
you're trying to portray i mean nato
is you know there is no consensus for
various reasons but you know the the
russian armed forces are inept
ineffective
and frankly they're a bunch of cowards
because they are unable to conduct a
proper military operation they could not
do it in syria they could only bomb
innocent people in syria they could not
conduct in chechnya and they're
repeating this in ukraine so in my view
the actual ability if a political
decision was made
by nato and it would have to be by nato
again so really i'm not the one taking
decisions but if i were
my
you know my fear my my my calculation
about the ability of nature to actually
impose it is much more optimistic
because of the complete shambolic you
know corrupt way you know we're talking
about not just war crimes but playing
pillaging which the russian soldiers
engage with they are not able to fight
openly with the ukrainians so in other
words if nato decided to go with yes
with the risk of the third world war the
factor you know but i'm pretty sure that
he would be able to overcome the russian
military forces that is the reality but
again i come back to the point this
message has to get through
it is getting through to a lot of people
uh in different capitals but at the same
time you know we need to have you know
respect the fact that you know there is
uh you know
nato countries are democratic countries
and they all you know look at the
situation from the point of security of
the people that they represent and one
cannot
neglect this so in other words we are
where we are today but if russia
continues this barbaric war who knows
you know the public opinion men actually
uh you know changed the the views of the
people who made those decisions at the
moment you know uh the the main effort
has to be on helping ukraine with
defensive with military assistance and
that is happening as we speak and that
is the most important thing that we can
do right now in other things
alexia we only have a little over a
minute left it looked like you might
have wanted to respond to what robert
was saying so i'm going to give you a
chance right now
look i mean it all comes down to the
point okay if nato will agree on on
using uh using military force to
intervene who is going to do it
i mean clearly it's not going to be
estonia who was the first to vote for it
so it's going to be established military
powers we also need to remember
just give me a second please also need
to remember that you need to give full
credit to the ukrainian military
in in in the context of the of the of
the of the ukraine's defensive posture
ukraine right now or at least prior to
the war deployed one of the most
effective military forces in some
instances superior to some of the
militaries
of a number of uh
nato member countries i mean if russia
is so bad in its uh
in its in its combat performance well
why don't uh generals in in brussels
make a quick decision and and destroy
the force that according to you is is
performing so badly so i think
you know we need to we need to
understand the realities on on the
ground and we also need to understand
the complexities of the situation and
when we discuss in war it's important
that the war is discussed by
uh people who actually understand the
business of warfighting not not people
who are making empty promises and who
are not going to end up fighting
who are not going to go to the front
line to actually confront that force so
before you simply say and make promises
about destroying the force assess it
first and then make make your decision
and clearly this is where nato has been
stuck with it
with that assessment all right well we
have run out of time so we're going to
have to leave the conversation there
today thanks so much to all of our
guests helena yanchenko robert pistel
and alexei moraviev
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website al jazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story for me
muhammad jim zhum and the whole team
here bye for now
[Music]
you